now to washington where vice president
kamala harris has tested positive for
the coronavirus though we're told she's
not experiencing symptoms it comes as
congress debates another round of covert
relief amid surprising new data about
how widespread the virus has been in
this country nancy cordes is following
it for us at the white house nancy good
morning
good morning tony and we're told that
vice president harris is feeling well
enough to work from home as she isolates
she is expected to remain there at the
vice president's residence not come back
to the white house until she tests
negative
vice president harris had just arrived
at the white house for a meeting with
the president tuesday morning when a
routine covid test came back positive
she got back in her motorcade and headed
home we had a very very contagious
variant out there the president's new
covid response coordinator dr ashish jah
says it's impossible to fully protect
even major officials from getting
coveted the goal of our policies should
be
obviously minimize infections whenever
possible
but to make sure people don't get
seriously ill
the best ways of doing that are making
sure people are vaccinated and boosted
as the vice president is and making sure
we have plenty of therapeutics after
consulting with her physician vice
president harris was prescribed and has
taken paxlevid the pfizer antiviral pill
the 57-year-old vp had just returned
from a trip to los angeles and san
francisco the last time she was in close
proximity to the president was last
monday at the white house easter egg
roll
[Music]
she now joins the roughly 60 percent of
the u.s population who have contracted
covid democrats argue rising case counts
underscored the need to pass a bill that
would redirect 10 billion dollars in
unspent relief funds to help buy more
drugs vaccines and testing equipment i
would urge our republican colleagues to
pass covet relief asap it's very risky
for the health of the american people
for them to be playing political games
with it
debate over that bill continues
meanwhile some good news for parents
pfizer yesterday submitted an
application for emergency use
authorization of its covid booster for
children aged 5 to 11. the fda says it's
going to release a schedule next week
for how long it expects it will take to
review the data and hopefully approve
the request
vlad
all right nancy quartus for us thank you